et en france ce sont toujours près de 5
millions de personnes qui sont encore
privées donc d'électricité je vous le
disais parfois eu des villages entiers
exemple à corcieux dans les vosges où
depuis dimanche
la population tente de faire face à la
situation
puis un kelly jan schmid corcieux fait
partie de ces communes qui ont subi de
plein fouet le passage de la tempête
des dégâts matériels plus d'électricité
et plus doux pour certains quartiers on
a pas d'électricité ni de chauffage
comment vous faites ben on allume des
bougies et pour se chauffer les bougies
ben n'a rien quoi on a froid mais là on
vient de réquisitionner terme à
l'entreprise
marcia à corcieux afin de pouvoir
desservir les habitations qui est qu'ils
n'ont plus d'eau à l'heure actuelle une
citerne réquisitionnés dans le cadre du
plan orsec premiers destinataires la
maison de retraite ici quelques groupes
électrogènes ont déjà été installés nous
n'avons plus tôt à l'heure actuelle plus
d'électricité
et puis voilà hier sans téléphone
combattants c'est un peu nul on est dans
la catastrophe c'est cette série
viennent ensuite les foyers privés d'eau
d'abord averti par la police municipale
les habitants sont aidés par les
pompiers et plusieurs bénévoles de la
croix rouge et de la protection civile
comment on vit 100 ans on m'a mal
combien s'entend c'est un peu la panique
mais sinon bon ça va une situation qui
dure depuis dimanche et si certains
gardent encore le sourire il ne faudrait
pas que ces pénuries se prolonge dans le
temps
le plan orsec est donc maintenu des
citernes sont déjà en place dans une
dizaine de communes et des bouteilles
d'eau minérale sont régulièrement
distribués au total dans le département
des vosges actuellement 2000
professionnels et bénévoles sont engagés
dans l'aide et le soutien à la
population